- [Voiceover] The first,
I guess you could say,
modern conception of an acid and base
comes from this gentleman right over here,
Svante Arrhenius, and he was actually
the third recipient of the Nobel
Prize in Chemistry in 1903.
And his definition of
acids, under his definition
of acids and bases, an acid
is something that increases
the concentration, increases
the concentration, concentration
of Hydrogen protons,
and we can say protons
when put in an aqueous solution,
when in aqueous, aqueous solution,
and that's just a water solution.
And then you can imagine
what a base would be.
You could think, oh
maybe a base is something
that decreases the protons and that's
one way to think about it.
Or you could say, it decreases,
or actually let me
write this, it increases
the hydroxide concentration.
It increases the hydroxide concentration.
when put in aqueous solution.
When in aqueous, aqueous solution.
So let's make that concrete.
Let's look at some examples.
So a strong Arrhenius acid, and actually,
this would be a strong acid
by other definitions as well,
would be hydrochloric acid.
Hydrochloric acid,
you put it in a an aqueous solution.
So that's the hydrogen.
You have the chlorine.
You put it in an aqueous solution.
You put it in an aqueous solution,
it will readily disassociate.
This is a, this reaction occurs,
strongly favors moving
from the left to right.
You're going to have
the chlorine strip off
the two electrons in the
covalent bond with the hydrogen,
leaving the hydrogen with no electrons,
so the hydrogen is just going
to be left as a hydrogen proton.
And then the chlorine,
the chlorine has just
nabbed that electron.
It had the electrons it had
before, and then it just nabbed
an electron from the
hydrogen, and so it now has
a negative charge, and these are
both in aqueous solution still.
It's still, they're still
both dissolved in the water.
And so you see very clearly here,
you put this in an aqueous solution,
you're going to increase the amount of,
you're going to increase
the amount of hydrogen ions,
the amount of protons in the solution.
And we've talked about this before,
you'll often see a
reaction written like this,
but the hydrogen protons,
they just don't sit there
by themselves in the water.
They are going to bond with the water
molecules to actually form hydronium.
So another way that you'll
often see this is like this.
You have the hydrochloric acid,
hydrochloric acid.
It's in an aqueous solution,
just a fancy way of saying
it's dissolved in the water,
and then you have the H2O.
You have the water molecules,
H2O, and you'll sometimes see written,
okay, it's in its liquid form,
and it's going to yield.
Instead of just saying that
you have a hydrogen ion
right over here, you'll
say, "Okay, that thing,
"the hydrogen is actually gonna get bonded
"to a water molecule."
And so what you're gonna be left with
is actually H3O.
Now this thing, this was a water molecule,
and all it got was a hydrogen ion.
All that is is a proton.
It didn't come with any electrons,
so now this is going to
have a positive charge.
It's going to have a positive charge,
and we could now say
that this is going to be
in an aqueous solution, hydronium
is going to be in an aqueous solution,
and you're going to have plus,
now you're going to still
have the chloride ion,
or it's a negative ion,
so we call it an anion.
Chloride, chloride anion,
and this is still in an aqueous solution.
It is dissolved in water,
and remember all that happened here
is that the chlorine here
took all of the electrons,
leaving hydrogen with none.
Then that hydrogen proton gets
nabbed by a water molecule
and becomes hydronium.
So even by this definition you might say
it increases the concentration
of hydrogen protons.
You could say it increase the
concentration of hydronium,
of hydronium right over here.
Hydronium ions.
So that makes, by the
Arrhenius definition,
that makes hydrochloric
acid a strong acid.
That makes it a
strong acid.
Now what would be a strong base
by the Arrhenius definition
of acids and bases?
Well one would be sodium hydroxide.
So let me write that down,
so if I have sodium hydroxide,
sodium Na, that's the sodium,
and then I have the hydroxide.
That's an oxygen bonded to a hydrogen.
So that's sodium hydroxide, and actually
if you wanted to see what
this molecule looked like
you have a oxygen having a covalent bond
to a hydrogen.
Let me do these in different colors.
Oxygen has a covalent bond
to a hydrogen.
to a hydrogen right over here.
And it actually has three alone pairs.
It actually has three alone
pairs right over here.
It's actually nabbed the electron from,
from somebody some place,
and so it's going to
have a negative charge.
It is going to have a negative charge.
Actually I could write it both,
let me just write it like that.
It has a negative charge,
and then you have a sodium ion
that has lost its electron somehow.
So you have a sodium ion that has lost
an electron somehow, so
it has a positive charge,
and for all we know, it
could have lost the electron
to the oxygen right over
here, making the oxygen
negative and making the sodium positive,
and so this is now
positive, this is negative,
they're going to be
attracted to each other,
and they form an ionic bond,
so sodium hydroxide,
they have an ionic bond
because the sodium is actually positive,
and the hydroxide part right over here.
That is negative,
and that's what draws them together,
but anyway, you put this
in an aqueous solution.
You throw some sodium hydroxide
into an aqueous solution,
it will disassociate into,
into sodium with its positive
charge, the sodium ions,
and actually you know the sodium
ion is still part of this.
That's what makes it attracted
to the hydroxide anion,
but it's still going to be
in an aqueous solution,
and then you're going
to have the hydroxide.
You're going to have the hydroxide anion,
so essentially this
thing just disassociates.
This has a negative charge,
and it's still going to
be dissolved in the water,
so aqueous solution.
So you throw sodium hydroxide in water,
it's going to increase the concentration.
It's going to increase the
concentration of hydroxide
in the water.
It's going to increase the
hydroxide concentration,
and so by the Arrhenius
definition of acids and bases,
this would be a strong Arrhenius base.
This would be a strong,
a strong base by the Arrhenius definition.
Now, and I encourage you to look at that
relative to the other definitions,
the Bronsted-Lowry
definition of acids and bases
and the Lewis definition
of acids and bases,
and see how you would think
about categorizing things.